physiquement je dois détruire votre cas
vous n'avez pas payé votre et ce n'est
pas possible
repassez là dans la machine ma carte est
valide tandis qu'on n'avait pas de carte
dirhams 10 s'agit que vous venez de
masse
c'était un peu j'ai dépassé ma ligne je
ne m'en sert que pour acheter du café et
de l'essence en floride
le centre nautique le grand bleu ça me
dirait habite au colorado is n'est pas
au bord de la mer on est au milieu des
terres vous deviez vous présenter devant
une cour de la floride il ya trois jours
je n'ai jamais mis les pieds en floride
sortait le registre on fait qu'ici ça
d'après moi c'est la personne qui a volé
votre identité
votre reçu la carte main garder la
sphère regarde là on dirait un robin je
peux me chercher d'elle je vais pour
chasser bill pour voyons c'est insensé
comme si tu étais justicier batman quoi
salon faire mal
il faudrait aussi changer nos
coordonnées samedi beghal aux personnes
mégalo c'est un drame s'est passé mon
nom de famille jérémy ab gallo était un
célèbre trappeur d'ours et sûrement
convaincu moi si mon permis de conduire
avec mon nom sans des bagarres aux
personnes j'étais coincé
on a des choses à régler
réglons ça comme des adultes
rien
ô dieu merci heureusement tu n'es rien
ouais toi ta voiture de location est
atteint j'en ai de la chance la voiture
en arrière mais le plus important
t'aurais dû mettre ses clignotants